hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 3rd of November today and you're
watching Gamespot
[Music]
news for those of you who like to
nitpick resolutions and that seems to be
the vast majority of the internet lately
you probably want to know that Call of
Duty Advanced Warfare is a tad inferior
on Xbox One this distinction however is
pretty damn small while the game runs at
a native 1920x 1080 on PS4 at 6 frames
per second the Xbox One version will be
outputting at 1360 by 1080 but still at
60 frames per second Sledgehammer Games
co-founder Michael condry confirmed the
details during a recent Reddit AMA
explaining that the res on Xbox one will
dynamically scale from its Baseline to
full
1080p as far as the upcoming holiday
console war goes Microsoft has said that
their $50 Xbox One price cut is just
what they need to compete with the PS4
the now
$350 Xbox One was a big move for
Microsoft according to head of Xbox Phil
Spencer during the latest Major Nelson
Radio podcast Spencer explains the
pricing that's going to run through the
holidays is a big move for us I think
it's a good time for us to go in and
let's just say it compete the Xbox One
is now cheaper than the PS4 for the
first time and the discount extends to
the various Xbox One bundles available
which include either Sunset Overdrive
assassin's Creed Unity or Call of Duty
Advanced Warfare spenzer explains that
the mey discount was planned months in
advance and he's optimistic about the
selling potential of the Xbox One this
holiday season Xbox one may have it un
loock for this holiday season but it
seems Microsoft may be struggling with
the amount of games they're due to
release in holiday
2015 Phil Spencer said he isn't
intentionally trying to Hype up the Xbox
one selection with this statement but he
honestly doesn't know if they can ship
all of the games due out in that window
when they're currently scheduled to
release he said it might just be too
crowded and we might purposefully try to
move some things around to spread it you
have to give them some breathing room
you have to do that so far we're
expecting Halo 5 Guardians Rise of the
Tomb Raider and Quantum break around
this period although Microsoft hasn't
released their full official holiday
2015 lineup as yet Spencer added that
games can Thrive outside the holiday
release window s the examples of Red
Dead Redemption and various God of War
Games as for your question of the day
let me know if you like your game
releases spread out or you prefer them
ASAP for more stories you can visit
games SWOT where we've got bits and
pieces on the Evolve Alpha and Call of
Duty Advanced Warfare download issues
that is it for me today I'll have a
bunch more news for you same time
tomorrow so be sure to check back
[Music]
then